[Music]
I'm picturing this is a kind of
double-oh-seven interview both the
Republican and Democratic establishments
were shaken by the New Hampshire primary
which had Donald Trump and Bernie
Sanders clearly and convincingly in the
lead the Democratic establishment will
stay in Hillary Clinton's corner
especially since there still remains
doubt about whether Sanders can win
black and Hispanic Democrats and large
numbers he didn't have to do that to win
New Hampshire but he would have to do it
to win the Democratic nomination The
Situation's a lot murkier on the
Republican side Republicans still don't
want Donald Trump as their nominee for
the most part but the party
establishment isn't sure who to get
behind instead Ted Cruz who beat Trump
in Iowa is disliked by many members of
the party establishment and the party
salesman hasn't decided whether it
prefers John Kasich Marco Rubio or Jeb
Bush to be their champion South Carolina
will tell us which of them that they
pick and set up the possibility of a
three-person race going forward right on
zero do you think that Sanders and Trump
will win the nomination or will the
establishment ultimately prevail let us
know in the comments and let us know
also if you think there are any other
topics that a EEI scholar should cover
in 60 seconds